[Music]
in inappropriate outfit news Oh
buta submitted my chickpea oh you little
put that number to or tricks a Miami
High School has apologized after video
of its dance team performing and
lingerie went viral what do they do
dance like a stripper with their legs
spread I would beat my daughters us what
about Micah oh I can't have double
standards I'd be disaster he's got a
beat his ass yeah you better not be
wearing that negligee at school Tyco I
swear to god water what's what's worse a
girl that's like 16 but looks like she's
25
dancing in lunch body 25 or face like
skin 25 just a woman so a 16 year old
looking like a 25 year old woman in
lingerie
dancing is that worse or a 25 year old
that looks 12 dancing in lingerie
which one I say to 12 year old 16 your
daughter is a 16 year old in lingerie
you're okay with that
[ __ ] no I'm not but I think a lot of
guys are so if you're just basing it on
just sheer age because then for me cuz
what's the crime here if a 30 year old
woman looks like she's seven years old
but she's wearing lingerie it looks it
makes me feel comfortable then it looks
like cuz it I feel like I'm looking at a
seven year old look away she wants she
look like she does I guess that's what I
feel what's the definition of grown-ass
woman
is it the low H or is it the a age her
mind her mind makes her a grown-ass
woman Selena Gomez is not illegal
yeah but she also doesn't look like 12
she just look she just looks young
Ariana Grande she's a little girl she's
over here yeah she's not much for me you
know you know that Gary Coleman thingy
yeah and the guys I never seen ladies
with that is that guy gene-specific
we're like guys look like boys but
they're like 30 years old like what's
his name the white kid Andy Milonakis
yep
oh and you oh yeah so if it was like a
lady
that's 40-something but she looks like a
little kid I'd be like that's every
Asian mom I'd be like that's a mug I
feel like a molester I can't be looking
at this [ __ ] I feel wrong even if she's
at the age of consent like way beyond
yep because I'm speaking from my heart
yeah right so like if I was like a
big-ish all right and there's like some
hot-ass gonna come out starts dancing
and I know or in my eyes feel like there
she's of age them all come and join the
show and then later when I find out
she's like 16 or something else Oh yuck
get away from me well I mean you only
say yuck because of laws though yeah see
yeah but but if they were all 40 year
old women and they all look like seven
year olds in lingerie I'd immediately go
Oh yuck what are these seven year olds
doing in lingerie and I would walk out
someone goes there are 40 years old I
would I wouldn't stay I'd be like I feel
like a pedophile being here I gotta go
yeah how about the situation at all I
answered it the way I did because it's
it's related to the story so I was
thinking as my daughter sixteen year old
that looks 25 on my that's wrong this
[ __ ] better not wear that [ __ ] so
that's how it was the answering your
question but the way you guys reacted to
it it's very normal cuz for me if my
daughter was in it
and I'm like hmm she does rock you're
pretty good but that's inappropriate but
you do look good what the [ __ ]
would you let her do it or not no I
would say don't do that but you did a
good job
mmm I already I already beat her for
[ __ ] wearing lingerie at that ease
but the whole team is wearing it I don't
give a [ __ ] if the whole team jumps off
the [ __ ] bridge you can [ __ ]
follow your whole team yeah understood
but what if the lingerie is like not bad
horny baby [ __ ] not granny panties
lingerie cuz girls they wear like
g-strings and thongs like when they're
like 12 already oh my god all right now
think about the girls your daddy they're
all waiting I see already five one at 12
yeah girls are buying Victoria's Secret
chef hello Lacey as well maybe now be
like 14 15 but Pok still dude especially
as time goes on it she's gonna get
younger and younger and younger with the
[ __ ] that she wants who are not helping
him and it's [ __ ] hard it's a tag
right now yeah he's the [ __ ] knees I
see sweat forming on his way my hands
are [ __ ] glistening dude I'm helping
you to understand and realize this and
accepting just by the time it comes
around like the you know I was prepared
for this [ __ ] some girls do like older
when they're younger I never be prepared
for that [ __ ] dude yeah I feel the same
way when they talk about him having sex
oh my god I know God never anyway maybe
I'm just not the same because I feel
like if my kid was 40
I'd still feel like they're my two year
old baby yeah I'm still my mom's the
baby yeah and I'm like [ __ ] an
amazonian freak you know dad but she's
still like what's it like onion be all
cute and small with me Oh cute alright
so this story so this high school like
your brother what hmm
Oh cuz like you know like there's this
stereotype well the brothers that I take
care of the little sister and we were
giving her brother a tour of our house
in the beginning and he saw like our
shower and he was like you guys going
baby baby yeah that came out of nowhere
they caught me off guard because usually
brothers when they look at their little
sisters like this dainty angel and then
for me I might not win haven't done it
in the shower yet and it he was like
what a waste
it's like do like I'm a dude you're a
dude so it's like we're just talking do
[ __ ] you know but they just caught me
off guard because if me and him were
just friends I would understand that but
I'm dating her little sister you're
married I'm married to little sister so
it usually does it different you talk
you don't talk about your little sister
like bent over and then making me write
these kind of noises with another guy
he's a comfortable man yeah he's very
cool it's not like that's what I said I
like a brother yeah he's not he's not
too serious yeah but that's a good time
there's even comfortable table so this
high school is called Miami northwestern
senior high school and it's also Miami
it's hella hot out there it just looks
like lingerie but it's just summer
outfit yeah so this video went up on
this website called flight height and it
went viral so here we go
which should we even be looking at this
right now it's a cheerleading don't want
my daughter in that their movement is
kind of sexual though it's very it's
very smooth and seductive okay yeah so
they aren't cheerleaders they're the
dance of the destiny all my ports of
these girls like twerking and doing a
lot of like sexually suggestive
movements yeah
that's kind of the dances that happen
right yeah yeah
no I'm saying like for them to do it at
an organized club I'm like yeah that's a
nice shirt well the thing is it's like
so there's a lot of layers to this one
this is the dance team so the dance the
female dance team one they have like
choreographed dance and then also to
make their stuff relevant not everything
could be classical dance so they do
incorporate things that are relevant so
twerking is part of it and then the
second thing is after I was going to
talk about the second team
the one is dance the second is being
relevant and I forgot the thing I think
what makes it taboo is the sexual
ization of the teens yeah so because
when I saw this I was like what is the
big [ __ ] deal because if you look at
the swim team and even though they're
wearing one pieces there's more skin
being shown in that than in this setting
it's more appropriate and then right
here they're saying like you know
there's kids up a game and they're just
like well I said yeah I was gonna say
but it is also kind of out of context
because what they're doing could be some
could be a piece that they choreographed
for their dance competition gloves and
drum line so it's kind of similar we
should be so later so you don't know
that though so in the context of their
stuff it's a bunch of girls competing
with a bunch of girls and the seductive
movements been happening since I was in
drumline since I was in high school so
you'll see stuff like that but it's just
now whatever they choreographed for
their competition is now brought to
centerfield which for them they're just
like well we're just performing what
we're gonna compete anyways and it's
just kind of a little bit out of context
cuz now it's in the middle of a football
field and now there's kids and all that
stuff so if this was kept in the dance
world it would have been okay because
I've seen stuff like this like girls and
leotards and like doing like the [ __ ]
you know the jazz walk where they take
one short step that one long wait how is
that sexual what the [ __ ] but that's
also very appropriate yeah yeah but they
have sexual versions of that what girls
are calling on the floor yeah for the
gasps [ __ ] like you have that high
school but stuff like down a football
field is totally inappropriate even
Beyonce the Super Bowl won't do that
after that Janet Jackson [ __ ] like
that's not gonna happen no the titty hit
mishap with Justin Timberlake yeah so
the dance teacher is a former Miami Heat
dancer and she's like the dance coach
and so she posted on her Instagram this
the big screenshots from other accounts
and she says so this is what viral feels
like publicity is publicity just that
more exposure for my young ladies and I
I wonder if Ellen and/or Wendy Williams
will
have my girls and the MMB perform on
their shows question mark what's the
name of their show
whatever P star performing did they talk
about that hookers on a runway show yeah
it might have like an actual show theme
and everything in so what's the
controversy besides the stockings well
it's just the fact that a lot of parents
are complaining to the school and saying
like hey you know this is too sexy like
this is inappropriate in this setting
and so that's when the the school
released a statement saying that it's
too sexy all the husbands we're getting
boners off no yeah they were just saying
that this school has always been a
source of pride for students parents
alumni in the community that they will
continue that tradition while all the
parents of the dancers who participated
in the event
approved of the attire to the school we
will we understand the concerns that
have been raised and sincerely apologize
for any offense this may have caused
looking ahead we will implement a more
comprehensive and stringent uniform
approval process to ensure an
appropriate representation of our school
so we do mention that the parents did
approve these outfit I mean the funny
thing is if you look at the outfit
they're pretty covered up yeah they're
more covered up than some dance teams
out there where it's what it represents
and it also looks like it's made by like
a uniformed company like with all the
like shiny shoes but you see lingerie
and you think sex and you don't want to
think sex and [ __ ] with me boots on
with with stockings and that's a fetish
but I think it's also like up to the
individual to interpret what they see
because I know a lot of young girls
right now their argument is basically
fabric to fabric like I mean that's what
makes it bad so you wear a bathing suit
to peace that's okay but underwear
that's made out of silk or lace or
whatever that isn't okay
it covers up the same equal amounts but
one is acceptable of one isn't and I
think people are sexualizing it right
but the person that's wearing it isn't
trying to act sexual about it so it
there's there's just controversy oh yeah
I think it's
Marketing behind what they're wearing
though dude I mean like yeah yeah so
that's I don't know I think that's why
it's just so uncomfortable and then
knowing that they're underage and you're
just like [ __ ] like why am I feeling
this but like you said like the dads
were probably getting turned on like I
literally think it's stuff like that
like it shouldn't like a 16 year old
shouldn't be like in this school setting
be like that out of all the things they
could have worn they could have worn
something else cuz for me when I saw
them move in sync like I was more like
oh [ __ ] they're actually really good me
too so like I was more like these guys I
wasn't getting hoarse or a good
performer yeah they were great they're
probably gonna go somewhere in life like
whether dancing for another artist or
whatever and I I didn't even like zoning
into the lingerie wasn't even like the
first thing that came to mind I actually
think the problem with the culture is
how much were afraid of sex and
expressing it and learning about it and
it's like of course if you're under 18
you're not of the mating age right but
that's probably the age where we should
be teaching them how to express
yourselves sexually and all that stuff
and really like to just shun it
completely is I think kind of weird I
agree but I feel like there's also a
time in a place that's what I was saying
that will change though if with
education the time in place it wouldn't
be so sexualized because it's so taboo
that's what makes it even more
sexualized
that's why same with like the time and
place teen it could be a poorly planned
place mmm but like with these like
school groups like in drumline like
whatever we learned that year we're
playing we're doing that at the rally
like that was the set that they prefer
for it was for some other dance
competition yeah so it could be like so
that they might perform that at the
school rally the football game at the
basketball game that's what they're
gonna compete with year long so they're
just practicing and getting better and
better and better and in the beginning
if maybe even if there was announcer hey
it's for the 2017 dance team today in
our ears or our show is called the West
Side Story or whatever like it to bring
full context to it it might actually
make it feel better you probably did
have a thing versus just oh my god look
top [ __ ] you know like because they
could be telling a story
like you're just kind of like diving
right into it and it's kind of like a
very microscopic view of what's going on
because one of the shows that we did
it's probably considered like culture
appropriation now but I was african
tribesmen and I had a grass skirt and I
had to like do these markings and stuff
and I'm play like banging on drums and
then if you see like a team of like half
Asian and half white people be in
African tribes minute and you just
squeeze I mean was probably like African
drummers or something yeah and it'd be
really weird but but we were we were
really trying to showcase this
polyrhythmic thing that we're able to
play but if you just took a screenshot
of like what happened bigger pie get in
trouble for that to you so for me like
I'm like if these girls are moving with
confidence and assume like they like
what they're doing and none of them are
like I'm so [ __ ] uncomfortable right
now oh my [ __ ] it they're they're not
showing a titty or a vagina also I
remember being in high school and it was
always about being a little bit of a
rebel and shaking [ __ ] up and you know
every [ __ ] generation is gonna do
something that like shocks the older
generation is gonna keep going my god
are you wearing that [ __ ] thanks for
watching guys and those are our thoughts
what are your thoughts don't forget to
comment below we want to know what you
guys are thinking but don't write
anything that will make it sad or make
us mad because after all we're just
kidding news and we're a very happy
channel for the last video click up here